ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
después de 12 días escalando una montaña
pasé uno de los peores momentos de toda
mi vida
hace dos años y con algunos de mis
mejores amigos al de nadie
mckinley una montaña que está en alaska
a tres grados del círculo polar ártico
es una de montañas más frías del mundo y
la más alta de norteamérica
les quiero platicar un momento un
instante que viví
yo que lo visualicen de la manera más
detallada posible
es una montaña que se sube por etapas tú
vas subiendo para aclimatarse para
acostumbrarte a la altura
y ya llegando a la última parte hicimos
un segundo intento a la cumbre pero se
empezó a cerrar el clima empezó a soplar
un viento horrible y no pudimos
continuar nos quedamos a 150 a 200
metros de la cumbre entonces de regreso
casi llegando al campamento llevamos 19
horas caminando ese día yo estaba harto
me arrastraban los pies porque ya no
daba para más estaba al borde desmayarme
de cansancio estamos tristes por no
haber hecho sima ese día varios de mis
amigos de los miembros del equipo ya
tenían síntomas de congelamiento en los
dedos de sus pies y en sus manos
y yo estaba
desde esperado
en la montaña montañas como está más
amarrado con tu arnés con una soga con
una cuerda a tu compañero de adelante mi
compañero primera acción es porque yo ya
no podía avanzar y en unos tirones me
hallo caí de rodillas y me pregunte de
una manera muy profunda pero muy real
qué carajos estoy haciendo aquí
después del momento
llegamos al campamento de los 17.000 10
yo me tiré en la nieve me caí me dejé
caer ahí con la cara en la nieve y
después un momento después grabé este
pequeño vídeo que les quiero mostrar
la realidad es que no fue tan mal día un
día terrible yo la pasé realmente muy
mal
yo lo llamo pavo gómez orea soy
comunicador soy emprendedor
soy conferencista y para ser de muy
sincero
mi carrera como atleta no tiene nada de
legendario
pero vivir este tipo de aventuras me ha
hecho preguntarme qué es lo que ha
llevado a los grandes exploradores de la
historia a querer ir más alto más lejos
o más profundo y que podemos aprender de
ellos para tener una vida más apasionada
y feliz
desde los grandes exploradores del siglo
pasado como ya justo que fue uno de los
inventores del sistema de buceo que hoy
conocemos y que estaba obsesionado por
descubrir el océano
edmund hillary que fue el primer hombre
en conquistar el everest o ernest
shackleton que trató de cruzar la
antártida pero su barco encalló y tuvo
toda una tradición y una experiencia de
sobrevivencia también la pasó muy mal
como yo
james dean y alex horne que son los
alpinistas del momento y que acaban de
lograr una gran hazaña escalando en
solitario y sin cuerdas la pared más
grande del mundo en yosemite y grabando
un documental padrísimo hasta los
emprendedores del momento como el los
mosca
el fundador de tesla que está impulsando
una nueva era de exploración en el
espacio
emprendedores fotógrafos alpinistas
buzos perfiles muy diferentes pero que
tienen patrones en común que los hacen
fuera de serie
he estudiado sus libros sus historias
sus ideas y el día de hoy les quiero
platicar cuáles son sus secretos para
que los llevemos a nuestra vida diaria y
la convirtamos en una gran aventura
primero aprovechan el dolor el miedo y
la desesperación para conquistar lo que
se proponen
cuando se hace la montaña hay veces que
vas en una arista caminando y tienes 600
metros para un lado de caída y 800
metros para otro
te da miedo
aqui en mexico lo decimos de otra manera
y probar cuando está soplando un viento
que te empuja hacia algún lado
el miedo es una reacción natural del
cuerpo y de la mente
de ti depende si te paraliza o te
impulsa hacia adelante segundo asumen
riesgos y fallan de manera repetida pero
ellos saben que es parte de la ecuación
del aprendizaje no se lo toman como un
fracaso y por último se salen de manera
constante de su zona de confort
algo impida pensar hoy pago entonces tu
propuesta de felicidad y de pasión
tienes que ver asumiendo en el miedo
haciendo riesgos
aprovechando el dolor saliendo de su
zona de confort en algo como esto la
aventura no es solamente escalar
montañas sumergirse en aguas congeladas
o cruzar la antártida
la aventura es formar una familia es
empezar una empresa
es crear un proyecto social
a mí me gusta entender la aventura como
una manera
de tratar y de conocer a dios a través
de la naturaleza otros lo ven como el
tiempo apasionado
de cualquier manera entender una
aventura como la crisis que conquistas
se asocia con la adversidad
se acostumbra al cambio y te convierte
en enemigo de la mediocridad
el mundo quiere vivir en la cima de la
montaña sin saber que la verdadera
felicidad está en la forma de subirla
están los demás estar en la parte más
alta la montaña es una gran experiencia
pero de nada sirve si no disfrutas el
camino
subir montañas no se trata de llegar a
un punto alto se trata de la amistad que
consigues estando amarrado a un
compañero que depende de ti y viceversa
se trata de la humildad de darte cuenta
que no eres nada y solo insignificante
que somos a diferencia de una gran
montaña
se trata de conquistarte anti mismo
el día de hoy les quiero dar tres
herramientas para que conviertan su vida
en una gran aventura
las montañas se suben dos veces primero
en la mente primero la imaginación y
luego en la realidad
tenemos que aprovechar la visualización
se tienen que imaginar palpar o leer lo
que quieren conseguir
segundo rutina
la rutina estaba matar depende cuál sea
tu rutina
si tú lo tiene implica asumir riesgos y
salirte de tu zona de confort vas a dar
lo mejor de ti
deben de tener una rutina ching go a
diario
por último la acción
la acción mata el miedo
de nada sirve ver estos vídeos estar en
estas charlas sino lo llevamos a la
práctica la acción nos construye
hillary la primera persona en llegar a
la cima del everest y regresar con vida
edmund tuvo una expedición fallida en la
que no llegaron a la cumbre y otra
expedición en la que lo consiguió y en
medio de esas en ese tiempo dio una
charla como la que estamos teniendo el
día de hoy
y al final de su conferencia edmund
mostrando una imagen del everest
señalando la cumbre dijo everest algún
día te conquistaremos porque tú seguirás
siendo del mismo tamaño y en cambio
nosotros habremos crecido
el poder de la aventura la escencia del
poder de la aventura está en el
crecimiento
cas de tutu
el último año
casi tutu el último mes que has hecho el
día de hoy
para conquistar las cumbres que están en
lo más profundo de tu corazón
peters
[Música]
[Aplausos]